foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing a Dumbledore
Voldemort and the Elder Wand more
specifically we're going to be
discussing a popular fan Theory which
suggests that Dumbledore was never the
true owner of the Elder Wand the Elder
Wand was the first hallow created made
by death himself and it was said to be
the most powerful wand that ever existed
the Elder Wand is made of Elder wood and
its core is the tale hair of a thestral
it 15 inches long and has carvings down
its length that resemble clusters of
elderberries with the Elder Wand witches
and wizards have historically been able
to produce intensely powerful magic that
others could only dream of some magic is
actually altogether impossible without
the Elder Wand including things like
mending are the ones we see this
powerful artifact pass hands on numerous
occasions throughout the Harry Potter
story and its ownership is of utmost
importance to the plot after all it's
the ownership of the Elder Wand that
eventually allows Harry to defeat
Voldemort firing his own killing curse
right back at him but before Harry
became its owner in his final showdown
with Voldemort the end of the Deathly
Hallows who were the true owners
conventionally It is believed that
Dumbledore was the owner followed by
Draco who disarmed Dumbledore followed
by Harry who disarmed Draco but one
popular fan Theory suggests the
Dumbledore was never the true owner at
all so when that leave us the main
driver behind the theory is how the wand
actually changes ownership
conventionally It is believed that a
witch or wizard can only become the true
Master of the wand if they best the
previous owner but what does best mean
while it was originally suggested that
besting or wizard meant defeating them
the Harry Potter story seemed to suggest
later on that besting can include an act
as simple as disarming I.E Draco with
Dumbledore but is that true the theory
in question suggests that disarming is
definitely not a valid way of obtaining
ownership and that in order to become
the true owner of such a powerful object
you need to take it forcefully
commanding the one's respect if we Trace
back the ones history we can see that
Dumbledore took the wand from
Grindelwald and if we look at how
Grindelwald obtained the wand we can see
that he did so in a cowardly manner
stealing it from Miku gregorvich in the
night gregorovich burst into the room at
the end of the passage his Lantern
illuminated what looked like a workshop
wood shavings and gold gleamed in The
Swinging pool of light and there on the
window ledge sat perched like a giant
bird a young man with golden hair in the
Split Second the Lantern's light
illuminated him Harry saw the Delights
upon his handsome face then the Intruder
shot a stunning spell from his wand and
jumped neatly backward out of the window
with a crow of laughter the theory is
this because Grindelwald stole the wand
in a cowardly fashion he was never its
true owner and because Dumbledore took
the one from Grindelwald who is not his
true owner he himself could not have
become the true owner this means that
for years and years even though it was
not in his possession meet yukagorovich
was the true owner of the Elder Wand but
if all of this is true how did Harry end
up becoming the ones true owner did he
well it starts with Voldemort becoming
Yona Voldemort who wanted to escape the
unique circumstances regarding his and
Harry's ones ended up tracking down
olivender after finding him Voldemort
tortured and interrogated him for
information pertaining to the Elder Wand
to this olivender reveals that he had
heard a rumor that Miku gregorovich
still had it in his possession the
prospect of obtaining a the most
powerful wand in the world and B an
instrument that could defeat Harry was
extremely intriguing to Voldemort and so
he vowed to track down gregorovich for
months Voldemort tracked gregorovich
down even murdering a family that lived
in his former residence along the way
eventually however Voldemort does find
gregorovich and it's at this point that
gregorovich reveals that the wand was
stolen from him years ago Voldemort who
did not believe him ended up using
legilimency to infiltrate his mind and
it was at this point that Voldemort saw
the truth a vision of the wand being
stolen from him years ago to this
Voldemort then demands to know who the
thief was something which gregorovich
reveals in Nevada found out at this
point gregorvich who pleaded with
Voldemort for Mercy was no longer of any
use to him and is killed by Voldemort's
killing curse at this point the theory
suggests that Voldemort without even
knowing it had become the Elder one's
true owner this means that Grindelwald
was never the true owner after stealing
it from gregorovich and it also means
that Dumbledore wasn't the true owner
after defeating Grindelwald though
Voldemort became the true owner by
killing gregorovich the one still wasn't
in his possession he would need to track
it down eventually however he does
finally wield the wand the only issue is
the disfabled powerful wand is just not
living up to his expectations he tests
it out time and time again and believes
there is no difference between his
ordinary ones and his powerful magical
artifact he eventually comes to the
conclusion that it's not a problem with
the wand but a problem with him yes he
now held the Elder Wand in his
possession but from his perspective
active because Snape had killed
Dumbledore Snape was the true owner not
him this meant that the wand would never
work to its full capabilities it's not
until Voldemort finally killed Snape and
he becomes completely satisfied what the
theory suggests here is that though he
was the rightful owner at this stage the
reason he lacked power was for reasons
unrelated to the wand or the one's
ownership Voldemort didn't lack power
because he wasn't a true owner he lacked
power because pieces of his soul were
being destroyed he was the owner of the
Elder Wand now sure but many pieces of
his soul had been destroyed without him
even realizing it making him weaker and
weaker when Harry scores a victory of a
Voldemort later in the story destroying
him it's only at that point that Harry
becomes the true owner this theory is
only reinforced by Rowling who seems to
suggest that it takes a great deal for
the wand to properly change allegiance
The Elder Wand is simply the most
ruthless of ones in that it will only
take into consideration strength one
would expect a certain amount of loyalty
from one's wand so even if you were
disarmed while carrying it even if you
lost a fight while carrying it it has
developed an affinity with you that it
won't give up easily if however a wand
is won properly one in an adult Jewel
then a wand may switch Allegiance
however the Elder Wand knows no loyalty
except to strength it's completely
unsentimental it will only go where the
power is so if you win then you've won
the wand you don't need to kill with it
but almost inevitably it attracts
Wizards who are prepared to kill and who
will kill and also it attracts Wizards
like Voldemort who confuse being
prepared to murder with strength in
essence this Theory closes the plot hole
that simply disarming your opponent
counts as besting them what do you guys
think of this Theory had you heard of it
before let me know in the comments
section below if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time it does not
do to dwell on dreams and forget to live